want to know what's heating up theaters  this weekend an heiress believes that  she is haunted by the souls of those  killed by a rifle in Winchester the  house that ghost built I can feel it you  can save your friends or you can save us  all a young hero leads his friends on  their final and most dangerous mission  yet in Maze Runner the death cure in  desolation three people travel into the  remote wilderness on a solemn mission  but are disturbed by a mysterious hiker  do you see what's hot in theaters with  this week's fantasy patient so what's  your weekend ticket going to be let us  know by commenting see you next time on  weekend ticket  [Music]